[Musica]
pensiamo a quelli italiani a quelle
italiane che il 23 giugno del 1946
furono chiamati a votare per fare un
uomo futuro ad un paese che è riuscito
distrutto moralmente fisicamente da una
guerra persa e combattuto dalla parte
sbagliata
adesso riflettiamo sulla opportunità
nuove che la democrazia digitale può
offrire
allora quegli italiani e quelle italiane
che votavano per la prima volta
potrebbero formarsi un'opinione se
sapevano leggere sui quotidiani ce
n'erano pochi ed avevano solo quattro
pagine perché non c'era la carta per
stamparli eppure quelle italiane con gli
italiani andarono a votare il 90 per
cento degli aventi diritto votarono e
più di 4 milioni di cittadini italiani
decisero di aderire ai partiti nuovi che
erano nati dopo la caduta del fascismo
con ritorno della democrazia
questo ci insegna che bisogna sempre
distinguere tra le idee di valore
fondamentale che sono propri della vita
democratica e gli strumenti che cambiano
necessariamente del tempo questo era un
concetto molto chiaro i costituenti che
dedicarono molta attenzione ai principi
fondamentali sapevano che la democrazia
non è solo chiamare il popolo a votare
una volta ogni tanto vuol dire che ci
sia un sistema di libera opinione che ci
sia la libertà di associarsi i partiti
sindacati associazioni libere vuol dire
una libera stampa vuol dire una
indipendenza dei poteri perché la
democrazia non è mai un potere assoluto
è dato dall equilibrio tra poteri
diversi e la costituzione e la patria
comune dei diritti sapevano i
costituenti che i diritti di libertà
avrebbero portato con sé i diritti
sociali
il diritto di eguaglianza un diritto
all'istruzione alla sanità dedicarono
molta meno attenzione alla parte degli
strumenti la forma di governo
il bicameralismo il sistema delle
autonomie locali il presidente
dell'assemblea costituente finendo i
lavori dice molto chiaramente noi
abbiamo fatto la nostra parte
toccherà a chi viene dopo di noi di
migliorare la strumentazione sulla base
dell'esperienza correggere gli errori
per questo ho pensato di raccontarvi una
piccola storia
io ho iniziato a fare politica volto
giovane quasi mezzo secolo fa era una
realtà tutta diversa appunto non c'era
la rete non c'erano i social non c'era
neppure i telefoni portatili si
chiamavano all'inizio i cellulari quelli
piccoli calcolatori che portiamo in
tasca come un'enorme potenza di calcolo
cosa c'era c'era il volantino era lo
strumento della propaganda che si
stampava il più delle volte con un
mitico ciclostile era una piccola
stampatrice bisognava incidere con una
macchina da scrivere manuale allora
meccanica non c'erano quelle elettriche
una matrice che era un foglio di carta
cerata che si agganciava un rullo
inchiostrato e girando la manovella o
per i più fortunati accendendo
l'interruttore si stampavano questi
volantini l'aggettivo digitale poteva
applicarsi a una sola cosa erano le
impronte delle dita e più delle volte si
baciavano sui primi fogli perché le
ditate uno sport che dell'inchiostro
tipografico eppure questa semplicità di
strumenti consentiva una grande
partecipazione politica dei cittadini la
politica vista
come un'occasione di riscatto sociale
più avanti alla fine degli anni 80 ho
fatto il sindaco di padova ancora non
c'era nulla di ciò che c'è adesso il
sindaco non aveva neanche un addetto
stampa non aveva lo spin doctor non
aveva né social manager tutta
quell'apparato che accompagna oggi il
sindaco che tra l'altro con l'elezione
diretta ha avuto una forte
personalizzazione però c'era un rapporto
vivace con l'opinione pubblica che era
intermediata da partiti molto forti da
associazioni civili dai quartieri eletti
direttamente dai cittadini contavano
ancora parecchio i media tradizionali
padova aveva quattro quotidiani
iniziavano a nascere le prime
televisioni locali e quindi c'era un
filtro esigente dell'opinione pubblica
rispetto a chi esercitava il potere
poi sono stato eletto al senato
qui si ho trovato il mondo cambiato
dall'eruzione delle nuove tecnologie
digitali
qualunque cittadino lo avesse voluto
poteva accedere al sito del senato
seguire in diretta i lavori parlamentari
accedere a tutti i testi in votazione
sentire gli interventi le proposte di
modifica e poteva con una semplice e
mail interessare i cittadini criticando
piuttosto che lodando chiedendo
chiarimenti proponendo modifiche
facebook non aveva la diffusione che a
oggi ma comunque anche gestendo in modo
artigianale una pagina facebook era una
finestra importante per il rapporto con
i cittadini
questa piccola storia mi serve a
sottolineare ancora una volta gli
strumenti servono e cambiano ma è
importante conoscere sempre le
fondamenti delle idee di valore che
stando
della democrazia viviamo siamo diciamo
alle soglie siamo in presenza di un
ulteriore salto tecnologico molto più
potenti di strumenti oggi rispetto a
quando ho finito di fare il senatore
però sarebbe sbagliato pensare che gli
strumenti da soli possono risolvere una
crisi evidente della democrazia così
come l'abbiamo conosciuta dovuto a tanti
elementi perdita di potere degli stati
nazionali dentro un grande processo di
globalizzazione delle leadership
politiche molto deboli perché non
ancorate a visione del futuro e ha
solide radici ideologiche di pensiero
questo leadership schiacciata
necessariamente sul presente
sull'emotività e questo porta a meno
cittadini che partecipano alla vita
politica manifesto con la loro opinione
con il voto e cresce intanto parte
dell'opinione pubblica
un'idea di una democrazia meno
democrazia una democrazia autoritaria
siamo insomma in presenza di fenomeni di
cambiamento che come sempre sono
ambivalenti da una parte nuove
opportunità per i cittadini di
interloquire direttamente con il potere
politico senza intermediazioni
dall'altro però una politica che rischia
più di farsi dominare dai nuovi media
piuttosto che dominarli e usarli quindi
politici prigionieri della dittatura del
like quotidiano prigionieri
dell'acquisto di followers schiacciati
appunto sul presente
io penso che bisogna guardare con
attenzione a questa evoluzione avendo
presente due capisaldi che per me
restano validi da un lato
l'idea della forza di una democrazia
rappresentativa non è vero che uno vale
uno platone chiamava la politica all ars
regia è un'arte richiede delle
competenze specifiche e la capacità di
costruire relazioni mussner ha scritto
il famoso saggio la politica come
professione
attenzione non parlava dei
professionisti della politica
parlava delle competenze necessarie e
lui scriveva politica come professione
non vuol dire vivere di politica ma
vivere per la politica
accanto al valore della democrazia
rappresentativa
questa nuova cittadinanza civile che può
essere resa più forte dalla presenza di
queste tecnologie senza illudersi che
possa scavalcare la capacità della
pluralità degli strumenti democratici
perciò la democrazia vive della capacità
di ascoltare di confrontarsi di
apprezzare le diversità delle idee e
nella convinzione che una parola
vendetta ben argomentata possa costruire
il consenso consenso deriva dalla radice
latina cuba sentire la capacità di
sentire insieme la democrazia richiede
l'arte del dubbio creativo i se ei ma
che cambiano la storia qui tanti
scienziati hanno scrutato il cielo
galileo se non si fosse posto dei se e
dei ma non sarebbe uscito dalla trappola
di uno schema del mondo che non era
corrispondente alla realtà
quindi essere curiosi sapere esercita la
curiosità di un futuro che può venire e
se devo dire la verità pensando a questo
mio passato che ho attraversato sono
molto curioso di vedere il
dopo che viene come sarà grazie